نجوم ريال مدريد يودعون بنزيما وعشاق
الاتحاد بانتظاره
انييستا يواجه برشلونه في طوكيو الثلاثاء
المقبل
وفاه مشجع في الدوري الارجنتيني
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
بعدما تضاربت الانباء هل يبقى ام يرحل
بنزيما من ريال مدريد حسمت الامور اليوم
اذ ودع النادي الاسباني لاعبه الفرنسي بعد
14 عاما قضاها في مدريد فينيسيوس جونيور
كان اول المودعين في تغريده المؤثره على
تويتر تحدث فيها عن دور بنزيما في حياته
بدورها بدا جماهير نادي الاتحاد السعودي
في عمل تصاميم ونشر تغريدات متفائله بقدوم
بنزيما الى فريقها بعدما انتشرت انباء عن
اتفاقه بالفعل مع النادي الجداوي
نتجه الى فرنسا حيث ودع نيمار زميله
وصديقه المقرب ليونيل ميسي في رساله عبر
تويتر كتب فيها لم يحدث كما اعتقدنا لكننا
جربنا كل شيء كان من دواعي السرور مشاركه
عامين اخرين معك وكان نادي باريس سان
جيرمان اعلن امس عن رحيل ميسي من صفوفه
بشكل رسمي فيما لم تحدد رسميا بعد الوجه
المقبله للنجم المتوج بممتع لقطر
اهلا بالجميع نتطلع الى مباراه برشلونه في
طوكيو الثلاثاء بهذه الكلمات رحب اسطوره
نادي برشلونه السابق
بالنادي الكتالوني اذ يخوض برشلونه
الاسباني مباراه وديه امام فيس الكوبي
الياباني في السادس من يونيو في طوكيو
ويخوض اليوم برشلونه مباراته الاخيره
بالدور هذا الموسم امام سيلتا فيغو قبل ان
نسافر الى اليابان
في خبر محزن توفي مشجع في مباراه ريفر
بليتاسيه بالدوري الارجنتيني اثر سقوطه من
المدرج العلوي لملعب المباراه
وتم تعليق المباراه بعد 25 دقيقه فقط من
انطلاقها ونشر كليت بيانا مع فيه المشجع
البالغ من العمر 53 عاما ويدعى بابلو
سيرانو واوضح بان حادث لم ينتج عن حاله
عنف وانه ما زال مستمرا في التحقيقات